[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance international y France 24
esta semana ponemos el foco en el
fenómeno de la faz Fashion todo un
desastre medioambiental la moda basura
la según la ONU la industria de la moda
es la segunda más contaminante del mundo
para ello nos acompañan cuatro invitadas
en este estudio que ya les paso a
presentar Clara liberes encargada de
promoción y regulación de los actores
económicos de la organización csfd
Adriana seminario consultora
especializada en moda y marketing
digital bienvenida
Mariana castaño periodista fundadora de
ten Million Solutions asesoramiento en
comunicación sostenible bienvenida
Mariana Gracias Carlos y Daniela
Rodríguez cofundadora de la agencia Club
especializada en comunicación y
relaciones públicas de moda bienvenida
Gracias Carlos basura hoy nuestro asunto
en Primera Plana
las cifras son tozudas y muestran una
realidad preocupante compramos un 60%
más de ropa que hace tan solo 15 años
para ponernosla la mitad de veces El
Triunfo de la Fast Fashion de la moda
basura está provocando todo un desastre
medioambiental cada año la industria
crea más de 100 mil millones de prendas
de vestir y ahora presten atención a más
datos para fabricar unos pantalones
jeans se necesitan 7.500 litros de agua
que es aproximadamente la cantidad de
agua potable que bebe una persona adulta
en 8 años la otra consecuencia de
estación ya lo saben esas montañas de
basura textil en lugares como gana o el
desierto atacama en Chile repasemos
algunas portadas revistas sustantvel
hace en esta portada una analogía entre
la Fast Fashion y la Fast Food con una
hamburguesa llena de ropa y se pregunta
si estamos ante el final de este
fenómeno en el Fígaro el diario francés
se pregunta en este artículo si 10 años
después del drama del rana Plaza la
industria ha cambiado Recuerden el drama
de 2013 que ese edificio ilegal cuando
se derrumbó costando la vida a más de
personas la mayoría obreros que
fabricaban para marcas occidentales el
cougueado publicación dirigida
adolescentes Dedica un número a Cómo
decir No gracias a la Fast Fashion
Nosotros también vamos a dar algunas
recomendaciones en el tramo final de
esta edición bueno Clara los datos son
desoladores podríamos citar millones de
datos Cómo Hemos llegado hasta este
punto creo que Hemos llegado a este
punto por una falta obvia de regulación
es un modelo que ahora tiene un modelo
predador y que tiene un monopolio que se
ha iniciado como a finales o bueno en
los años 90 y un modelo que viene
inspirado de la gran distribución En el
que se tiene dos Pilares
un consumo excesivo y bajos precios esos
bajos precios están permitidos porque se
fabrica esos productos en países donde
no hay tantas regulaciones a nivel
social o a nivel medioambiental también
y por lo tanto hay gente trabajadora
sobre todo porque muchas mujeres son las
que fabrican nuestros en nuestras
prendas pues trabajan horas y horas para
un salario que no es nada digno Yo creo
que por ello Hemos llegado
esas cifras
importantes
de su acto de compra aquí la conciencia
yo creo que en el programa de hoy es una
palabra que vamos a tratar varias veces
Adriana Cuando hacemos Cuando hacemos el
acto de comprar un vestido una camiseta
por dos euros qué hay detrás de Ello hay
definitivamente una industria no
regulada hay personas explotadas hay un
consumo de recursos naturales humanos
que es realmente desproporcionado al día
de hoy yo siento que
hay Bueno hay muchas marcas que están
proponiendo una Fast Fashion que implica
no pensar realmente concretar una acción
de compra en un tiempo limitado meter De
cierto modo psicológica a una a una
parte de la población sobre todo la Los
Adolescentes la gente joven que está muy
en su naturaleza ser impulsivos pero es
muy importante recordar que
estos actos tienen un impacto en el
largo plazo en el planeta y el planeta
no realmente no tiene un largo plazo si
seguimos continuando de esta manera
Mariana Pues no no tiene No tiene largo
plazo si la industria textil fuera un
país sería uno de los más contaminantes
se emite el 8% de la emisión de gases de
efecto invernadero a nivel global lo
emite la industria textil es decir la
industria textil a nivel mundial emite
tanto que la Unión Europea la industria
textil contamina el 20% de las aguas
contaminadas que tenemos hoy el día
porque se utilizan hasta 8.000 productos
químicos diferentes en la producción y
sobre todo el teñir no y recientemente
lo hablábamos hace un momento
organizaciones no gubernamentales han
hecho análisis de qué trae esa ropa que
cuesta 2 euros y medio o sea el coste
laboral es muy importante el coste en el
agua Pero el coste en la salud la salud
del planeta y la nuestra porque se ha
descubierto que hay hasta plomo plomo
una sustancia prohibida esta hasta en la
pintura de nuestras casas en ropa de
bebé Entonces imaginaros el coste para
el planeta y para la salud de las
personas que tiene la Fast Fashion
Daniela me gustaría que explicaremos
cómo funciona esta cadena porque
hablamos de tiempos cada vez más
reducidos ya no hablamos de producción
rápida sino de Ultra rápida ya no
hablamos de temporadas sino de
microtemporadas cómo funciona esta
cadena Sí lo que pasa acá es que ya las
marcas dejan de tener este calendario
anual sino que empiezan a sacar
colecciones cada dos semanas cada semana
y nos están mostrando también en redes
sociales este cambio constante que hace
que nosotros queramos estar consumiendo
y consumiendo nueva ropa y que lo que ya
tengo que ya me puse y ya me tomé una
foto ya no lo uso nunca más Entonces
digamos que ese es el nuevo marketing en
cuanto a que estoy
tiempo bombardeado por mucha información
por como tengo que estar cambiando por
Cómo debo vestirme cada vez diferente Y
las marcas también van a ese ritmo
Entonces ya en vez de tener una dos o
tres colecciones cuatro anuales estamos
teniendo casi que 20 entonces es algo
que no es sostenible ni tanto para la
marca ni tanto para el consumidor ni la
para las personas que están trabajando
detrás siete veces la ropa diseñada bajo
el concepto de moda rápida se consume
solamente siete veces en promedio antes
de ignorarla o desecharla la uno dice
que es la segunda industria más
contaminante no sé si después del
petróleo No si somos más indulgentes con
con la ropa con lo textil que con el
petróleo totalmente totalmente porque es
una contaminación que no se ve es una
contaminación que desgraciadamente
se manda a otros países hay algunos
países que ya han prohibido la
importación de basura por ejemplo China
prohibió la importación de basura pero
no hay nada sobre la importación de ropa
que en principio para segunda mano Es
decir para que se recupere y se vuelva a
la ventas para poner a la venta en los
países economía en desarrollo sin
embargo esa ropa La mayoría de la ropa
que estamos viendo en imagen es de tan
mala calidad o de producto basado en el
petróleo de poliéster que no se puede
utilizar en países húmedos Y cálidos y
termina Pues en las playas y quien dice
que terminan las playas terminarán el
mar o termina incinerada y sabemos todo
lo que quemar plástico producen términos
de emisión y de contaminación del aire
no entonces una contaminación que no se
ve Hay también una tendencia un poco
perversa hoy en día con el efecto y me
va a permitir utilizarlo maricondo que
quiere decir
guarda solo lo que necesites y eso tiene
el efecto de que haya personas que
saquen del armario y pongan en el mejor
de los casos en el contenedor de la ropa
usada la ropa que no necesitan y tengan
la conciencia tranquila de que lo que
como no se ve es como si no existiera no
entonces tenemos que hacer un gran
trabajo por supuesto de regulación Yo no
creo en que la responsabilidad recae
100% en el consumidor pero un gran
trabajo de concientización a nivel a
nivel del consumidor individual y a
nivel de los que influyen al consumidor
individual que hoy en día antiguamente
pudiera cococha en él dior y el Louis y
actualmente son los influencers sobre
todo en redes sociales y vemos por
ejemplo en tiktok que shein pues parece
un gran escaparate No desde tiktok que
es muy importante tema redes sociales
vamos a vamos a ponerlo por tu nombre yo
creo que hay una hay un gran impacto
entre dos cosas la inmediatez de las
redes sociales Y el hecho de querer ver
las cosas ya ya de una vez y la idea de
que esto es unas acciones que van a
tener un impacto en el largo plazo y
digamos algunas cifras porque realmente
shein se ha convertido un poco en la en
la insignia en la marca insignia de la
Fashion que ha desplazado a otras que
eran por ejemplo hasta hace unos años
solamente Sarah occidentales en un día
produce la misma cantidad de CO2 que
centrales eléctricas en promedio unas
seis punto tres millones de toneladas de
CO2 al año que está muy lejos de la
reducción de 45% que se quiere lograr
para el 2030 que ha sido establecida por
las Naciones Unidas entonces realmente y
sin embargo dice hacen pop UPS en muchas
ciudades occidentales aquí mismo en
París han hecho popups y ha sido un
éxito absoluto Por qué Por qué las
personas realmente no tienen esta no
están desarrollando esta conciencia de
cierta manera es por los influencers es
por el youtuber que hizo un Hall de mira
todo lo que me compré en shein está
tiktoker de Conce millones de Seguidores
hizo un un video miren todo lo que me
compraba las críticas cayeron
inmediatamente y ella respondió con un
muy rotundo comprar sostenible es un
lujo no todo el mundo puede permitírselo
Daniela Clara
compartir lo que se ha dicho y también
es divertido bueno divertido a lo mejor
no es la mejor palabra pero por ejemplo
sabemos que emite muchos gases de
efectos invernadero y vale casi lo mismo
que la Aviación y el transporte marítimo
juntos Pero uno ahora por ejemplo cuando
coge un avión sabe que no está haciendo
algo bien para el planeta En cambio
cuando compra una ropa Pues no todas las
veces se se hace este tipo de
comentarios a sí mismo no porque somos
más indulgentes con la ropa que con la
Industria del petróleo yo siento que es
porque es algo de todos los días y lo
vemos como un pequeño algo que me pongo
me quito y es pequeño si me compro una
camiseta y la voto mañana que puede
pasar no veo el impacto a gran escala y
también siento que el tema de las redes
sociales y la comunicación de las marcas
muchas veces las marcas también hacen
este tema de Green washing en el que nos
dicen estamos haciendo esto O este
algodón es orgánico este algodón viene
de tanto entonces como que a veces
decimos Ah ya se solucionó el problema
pero no vamos atrás a ver puede que
estén solucionando una cosa pero detrás
de una prenda hay una cadena enorme que
si no regulamos O no entendemos pues no
vamos a ver ese ese cambio Qué
porcentaje de ese de algodón orgánico
hay en esa prenda y Qué porcentaje de la
prenda de las tiendas tienen algodón
orgánico o sea es que es el tema del
Green washing igual que lo hacen las
petroleras lo hacen la industria textil
hace 10 años existíamos impactados al
drama del rana Plaza el 24 de abril de
2013 tuvo lugar en bangladesh el mayor
accidente de la industria textil 1134
personas fallecieron al derrumbarse un
edificio de ocho pisos construido
ilegalmente la mayoría de las víctimas
eran obreros que confeccionaban ropa
para marcas occidentales Clara Qué
medidas Se tomaron desde entonces y Qué
efectividad han tenido bueno hace poco
hemos celebrado este triste aniversario
y diez años después hubo algunos cambios
puntuales pero no
cambio sistémico no hubo cambios en
bangladesh firmó varios acuerdos también
en Pakistán se ha renovado por ejemplo
la mitad de las fábricas en bangladesh
eso sí que está bien y por ejemplo
también generó un cambio muy importante
en Francia porque se adoptó tras este
shock Hubo mucho debate en Francia y se
adoptó una ley que sobre el deber de
vigilancia que impone a las grandes
empresas a las multinacionales pues
cuidar sobre todo la cadena de valor que
se respeten los derechos humanos y el
medio ambiente pero
tenemos que ir más allá en La regulación
y hoy en día se está negociando por
ejemplo en la Unión Europea una
directiva muy importante sobre el deber
de vigilancia para imponer a todas las
empresas europeas pero también las
empresas que venden productos en el
mercado de la Unión Europea Pues lo
mismo que en Francia con la ley del
deber de vigilancia vamos a hacer una
pequeña pausa en este punto pero en unos
instantes seguimos hablando de la faz
fashion aquí en Primera Plana hasta
ahora
[Música]
el mundo evoluciona cada vez más rápido
las noticias no esperan
Under
France 24 siempre estará a su lado para
comprender el mundo
para ofrecer la mejor información
internacional 24 horas del día
France 24 en todo lugar y cada momento
con usted
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo
miles de personas cada año se ven
obligadas al Éxodo a huir de sus países
en busca de una vida mejor Llevamos una
mirada humana a la migración masiva en
América Latina y en el resto del mundo
[Música]
acompáñenme en migrantes por France 24 y
France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
analizando la Fast Fashion recuerdos
según la ONU las la industria de moda es
la segunda más contaminante del mundo lo
hacemos con Clara liber encargada de
producción y regulación de los actores
económicos de la organización ccd
Adriana seminario consultor
especializada en moda y marketing
digital Mariana castaño periodista
fundadora de ten villion Solutions
asesoramiento en comunicación sostenible
y Daniela Rodríguez cofundadora de la
agencia Club especializada en
comunicación relaciones públicas y moda
antes de irnos a la pausa estábamos
hablando
del aniversario de los 10 años del rana
plaza de las medidas que se han tomado
desde entonces no sé si os podría
plantear es posible a día de hoy que se
produciera un drama parecido
sí Yo diría que sí y lo hemos visto en
tres esos diez años que hubo más
accidente incendios y también todo lo
del trabajo el trabajo forzado de los
también que es un tema o sea el impacto
sobre los derechos humanos es tan
importante como el impacto sobre el
medio ambiente Así que sí hemos visto
que se puede reproducir y por ello
tenemos que seguir con más regulación y
regulación con secciones también que las
empresas sienten que ya no pueden actuar
como están actuando Claro porque la
conciencia ciudadana es importante pero
el planeta no no nos da ese tiempo se
necesitan otro tipo de reglas de
regulaciones que vayan de forma más
rápido que la propia educación o que la
propia concienciación
Sí tienen que ser mucho más estrictas
pero también de la es tiene ambos lados
el lado medioambiental que lo vemos en
el largo plazo y el lado humano que es
muy concreto que podemos ver en
tragedias como esta en fábricas en
países como en China donde 75 horas
semanales son En rigor para trabajar
donde las personas pueden lograr 20
dólares diarios que se reducen hasta 14
dólares debido a que hay errores de
chura realmente de qué estamos hablando
ese ese sufrimiento que la gente Porta
que lleva encima cuando está comprando
Fast Fashion que realmente no es algo no
es algo sostenible solamente para volver
al punto anterior que decían que las
críticas a esta influencia que decían Sí
pero comprar sostenible Es muy caro no
es posible para todo el mundo realmente
es un acto
que va más allá de solamente mirar la
etiqueta de decir esta marca Me gusta y
el diseño está lindo realmente es una es
una idea de construir estilo Yo sé que
en las redes sociales esta imagen de
personal branding de imagen personal que
antes estaba reservada solamente a la
celebridades a las estrellas a los
grandes actores y que hoy día gracias a
los teléfonos portables todo el mundo
crea su imagen en estar en las redes hay
una tentación muy grande por consumir
todo el tiempo por renovarse por Mostrar
algo diferente Pero esta psicología de
de de renovarse todo el tiempo viene a
un gran costo Y eso es lo que me
gustaría de que se puedan debatir un
poco más me van a permitir que les haga
una pregunta que sé que es un poco
provocación pero que está ahí que yo
creo que hay que plantearla a raíz de lo
que decía Adriana que se me entienda la
cuestión los pobres quieren vestir a la
moda los pobres quieren viajar los
pobres quieren hacer turismo
democratizar tantas cosas no es
sostenible Mariana a ver Es que yo creo
que hemos caído un poco en el error de
aceptar la narrativa que la Fast Fashion
y empezó Zara a final de los años 90
democratiza la moda eso es un discurso
que no ha mostrado todo porque los más
pobres del planeta no tienen acceso a lo
que vende Zara por ejemplo no o sea
estamos hablando de más de 100.000
millones de prendas vendidas cada año la
mitad se compra en los países
desarrollados o economías emergente más
de la mitad de la población solo tiene
acceso a esa ropa que mandamos en barco
a los países en desarrollo o a ropa que
también de manera artesanal se
produciendo también y que probablemente
será de mucha mejor calidad que lo que
se comprado Euro y medio no Entonces
estamos hablando de sistema globales de
injusticia y desequilibrio que se están
acelerando a ritmo inauditos y por
supuesto como decía Carlos que el
planeta no puede aguantar a mí me
gustaría que hiciéramos un silencio de
uno dos tres segundos en tres segundos
tres camiones cargados de ropa se han
tirado a un vertedero donde no se va a
reutilizar esa ropa entonces hay que
reflexionar a la hora de comprar sin
necesidad existe realmente de hacer esa
compra eso por parte del consumidor pero
luego por parte de los gobiernos La
pregunta es bueno Quién le pone el casca
del gato quién corta la música mitad de
la fiesta
sí totalmente o sea a mí me parece muy
bien la directiva europea que está en
negociación la normativa francesa que
dentro de poco habrá En las etiquetas de
la ropa una indicación del impacto
climático de esa ropa me parecen medida
importante pero estamos hablando de un
grano de arena en el desierto porque
Francia puede ser un país bien
progresista la Unión Europea el día que
apliquen esa directiva también será
progresista Pero estamos hablando de
volúmenes mundiales que es que que nos
depasan a todo 90 millones de toneladas
de ropa se tira al año y quién dice
tirar dice que se van a quemar o que se
van a enterrar en un basurero la
pregunta moral un poco que le traslada a
Mariana me gustaría plantearlo también
al resto para al final una persona que
tiene un alquiler o que tiene que pagar
un alquiler que tiene una alimentación
para su familia si tiene que elegir
entre una camiseta de 30 euros o una de
tres Cómo podemos exigir una visión
ética en el acto de compra yo que haga
de abogado del Pero creo que es
importante plantearlo para mí es súper
importante lo que has dicho antes al
final la gente más pobre del mundo los
que hacen nuestras prendas son los que
sufren y yo creo que es informar
informar y no parar con este tipo de
emisión y también con las redes sociales
ojalá un día un influencer pues tenga
una comunidad que le sigue y que él vaya
explicando cómo se hace esas tiendas
Antes había la pregunta de que es una
contaminación que no se ve pero nosotros
como ong acompañamos muchas personas en
muchos países del mundo que ve cada día
la contaminación tenemos una asociación
en túnez que está peleando día a día
porque las Industrias textil en
monasterio una región de túnez donde se
produce muchas muchos textil pues tiran
productos químicos en la valla de en el
agua en el mar y Los Pescadores que
llevaban años y años pescando ahí ya no
hay ya no hay peces y cuando hay pescado
la gente lo come y tiene productos
químicos dentro
por eso es una cuestión de injusticia
climática económica entre los del Norte
y los del sur y por lo tanto es una que
es muy holística que que los gobiernos
que las personas tras la movilización
también ciudadanos lo hemos visto otra
vez con la cuestión de los wigurt cuando
se informan a las personas pues yo he
visto gente que ha parado de comprar en
Sara que ha parado de comprar en
esas tiendas que estaban en la lista de
los que trabajaban con los Daniela sí
digamos que algo que lo que decías de la
democrática democratización es demasiado
importante porque al final es A qué
costo estoy democratizando la moda
porque la persona que está detrás de esa
prenda o las personas que están detrás
de esa prenda qué calidad de vida
también yo les estoy dando al pagar una
camiseta de 10 euros 30 euros entonces
él se encuentra realmente ese balance ad
ingeniería cultural ha conseguido
vincular el cambio permanente de ropa
como sinónimo de éxito como pasa también
con el como con el culto al cuerpo yo
creo que nos han metido eso en la cabeza
yo creo que sí sobre todo los últimos
los últimos digamos diez años con la
explosión de las redes sociales
solamente viendo un poco que a finales
del 2018 Instagram ya contaba con mil
millones de usuarios al día de hoy en la
plataforma más utilizada y realmente
marca un símbolo de estatus un símbolo
social un símbolo de poco importa
realmente bueno en ciertos sectores como
el lujo Así que importa mucho pero en
ciertos sectores como el la moda un poco
más Fast Fashion en particular realmente
la gente no le interesa mucho donde
venga no revisa la etiqueta qué es lo
que quieren verse en la foto compartirla
tener la validación social de su círculo
o ahora Bueno realmente cualquiera que
pueda verlos en las redes sin embargo
solamente para comentar que sí hay
influencers ahora que se dedican un poco
más al tema de concientizar al tema de
la sostenibilidad al tema de quién está
fabricando
y mucho el tema de segunda mano se está
desarrollando ha explotado bueno es
también una industria y no nos no nos
vamos a mentir sin embargo es algo que
se ha desarrollado enormemente los
últimos años que tiene muchas ventajas
porque lo más importante todas esas
prendas no han pasado por todo el ciclo
de producción no han consumido todos los
recursos que se utilizan para fabricar
prendas desde un inicio Okay pero
tampoco es decirse OK ya no tengo me
eximo de culpa porque ahora cumplo de
segunda mano y entrar nuevamente en ese
círculo vicioso de comprar por comprar
más general que decirme el cambio a la
segunda mano vamos a ver si les parece
algunos consejos a modo de hoja de ruta
a la hora de a la hora de consumir
estábamos hablando de las tiendas de
segunda mano que están muy desarrolladas
por ejemplo en Berlín en Finlandia en
algunos
qué podemos Añadir que a ver Mariana mi
recomendación número uno sería la ropa
más sostenible es uno la que no se
compra y dos la que ya se tiene la que
tiene uno o su entorno yo por ejemplo
esta chaqueta que llevo tiene más de 20
años está hecha en España en su época es
de muy buena calidad y la ha podido
seguir usando durante 20 años esta
camiseta pues la heredado es de mi madre
era de mi madre Y estos pantalones
vaqueros que cuesta tanta agua
producirlo Pues los compré hace como dos
semanas en el sur de Francia en una
tienda de segunda mano al peso y me
costó 16 euros un pantalón que nuevo
cuesta 100 euros no entonces las
soluciones están ahí y empiezan por un
trabajo personal de reflexión yo creo
que pensárselo realmente dos veces a la
hora de antes hablaba de Es que tengo un
salario pequeño quiero comprarme una
camiseta pero no tengo los 30 euros
Bueno mira en tu armario o a tu
alrededor tal vez haya personas que ya
no se quieran poner lo que lo que
estaban poniendo y hay un intercambio de
ropa que yo se lo hago con mi con mis
amigas pero hay un trabajo también de
interno porque culturalmente y venimos
de cultura gelatina las ropa de segunda
mano se veía como que no podías acceder
pero también era porque esa mentalidad
viene de una época en la que la ropa
duraba en cambio ahora la ropa Es que no
dura me imagino que también hay que
evitar las compras impulsivas y las
tendencias muy temporales es decir ser
críticos a la hora por ejemplo de ver el
Instagram sí completamente hay que
entender que viene detrás de esa prenda
y buscar otro tipo de soluciones Por
ejemplo ahorita todo el tema de la de la
ropa de segunda es increíble porque es
encontrar esos pequeños tesoros que tal
vez nadie más tiene como los impregnó yo
en mi estilo personal en vez de estar
siguiendo una tendencia que al final
nunca va a ser sostenible porque también
estas mismas tendencias que nos muestran
Pues muchas veces las campañas la ropa
es prestada de las celebridades vemos la
ropa prestada o sea ni siquiera ellos
mismos están Están teniendo este nivel
de consumo Pues tampoco nosotros tenemos
por qué tener
será importante sin querer ser
nacionalistas pero lógicamente las
prendas están hechos en tu país o en
zonas cercanas es muy probable que la
huella medioambiental sea menor
definitivamente definitivamente en
Latinoamérica solamente por poner un
ejemplo sí que tenemos mucha cultura
ancestral de tejidos mucha cultura son
no solamente para ropa pero para
accesorios es algo que siento que en
este momento se está revalorizando en
ciertos países en Perú definitivamente
en Colombia sé que también es un poco
reapreciar la la cultura local digamos
el sabor pero en este caso de no
solamente América Latina sino de cada
región que puede un poco revalorizar y
eso también conecta de cierta manera con
la cultura con el origen con el tema de
identidad ha hablado Daniel algo muy
claro el tema de tendencias no nos vamos
a mentir las tendencias Por qué nacen es
parte de la industria de la moda y y la
palabra industria es clave en esto es un
negocio yo que lo que yo creo que es
importante es trabajar Lo que comentamos
previamente un trabajo interno un
trabajo personal de estilo qué es lo que
Define qué es lo que me Define qué es lo
que Define mis valores qué es lo que yo
quiero proyectar y dejar No dejarse
llevar un poco por toda esta marea de
información que vemos sobre todo en las
redes sociales en nuestros teléfonos
todos los días
la última frase que me quedaba unos
segundos sujeto verbo y predicado
Mariana sí la naturaleza no descarta la
naturaleza no genera basura las personas
tenemos que aprender a aplicar la
circularidad en nuestro en nuestro día a
día y no generar basura y tratar de
rechazar lo que no necesitamos rehusar
lo que ya tenemos reparar lo que se nos
rompe y reciclar lo que no se puede
devolveríamos con ese consejo Muchísimas
gracias a las 4 ha sido muy interesante
hablar con ustedes de ese fenómeno de
las fascina todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana en Primera Plana gracias